but it's going to be a fantastic display
yeah we plan the display for a year
mainly around how the city's going to
work and do sort of getting people in to
have a fantastic night but tonight we've
got as you said before 11 minutes and 14
seconds but it's a fantastic display the
fact that we've got UNICEF partnering
with us this year that's correct it's
basically the mayor mayor's office and
mayor of London and you've got a global
city of London partnering of the global
charity and the idea is that the viewers
at home but also those down here can
donate to UNICEF winter campaign either
by texting mouth to the number which is
on the UNICEF
put your money where you know this
indeed it is so the idea is to raise
money for children in Syria and they've
got a big campaign of running it through
the winter to help those children
correct when the idea is those people
down here you make those New Year's New
Year's resolutions one they can keep is
to donate to those children and help to
make their lives a better place
entertainers with some more facts and
figures well from the fireworks side of
things we start making the the display
in September we start designing it with
the music
that musics the back backbone to our
display and we create the rhythm and the
quirkiness and the the character if you
like something that's unique to London
this year we're starting with from the
UNICEF side of things some voices of
children you have to guess all the
voices and the different languages as we
go through which is basically welcoming
people to London finishing with Boris
welcome mr. London we're then going
through an eclectic mix of music tracks
and we're picking up on some of the key
moments in the year including the Rugby
World Cup and as well as some just two
reflections there's a very beautiful
track that's from Silla and this is a
moment for me yet you hope for your your
hair stand on end on that but the
display this year is very synchronized
we've got more queues than we've ever
done both from a lighting and a firework
point of view to create something that
is both spectacular here but also for
the O's viewers watching at home
okay so tell us that tell me about how
many of how much barriers we've got how
much fiber optics we've got blah blah
blah well from point of view of the
operations that going on there is huge
the footprint we take on is from Lambeth
bridge right down to Southern Ridge it's
around about a two and a half mile
stretch of the river we've got tonight
two and a half there 2,800 stewards my
team and total is about 3,200 guys
security side of things is you know
obviously high current through what's
going on in the world at moment we've
increased our security levels doing bag
checks which is taking it slower if you
like to ping Brit bill in but to make
sure that we've got a safe environment
down here but also the police you know
Metropolitan Police have increased their
their presence to make sure that we in
London can have a fantastic display
something that we'll be proud of and
something will be safe for the public
down what can go wrong well you
shouldn't lose me that no but the great
thing is we always watch the weather you
know if the display was last night
you've been very different
midnight indeed midnight last night we
were doing our tests just without the
fireworks it was dumping it down and we
had very strong winds which have made a
very very small display this year the
winds are dropping the blowing the smoke
in the right direction so we should have
the most spectacular display we've had
for many years